[Music]
well hello everyone and welcome to our
discussion with Matt Bailey on talking
today about the email practices that are
ethical or borderline and legal and also
updating you on the current compliance
issues such as gdpr
and of course just giving you some good
best practices that have been proven
throughout the year dan beavin I'm
simply learns director of training
research and your moderator today and
it's my pleasure to introduce you to our
esteemed guest Matt Bailey Matt Bailey
is a best-selling author marketing
expert corporate trainer and
professional speaker he's the founder
and president of site logic marketing
matt is the digital marketing instructor
for the Direct Marketing Association in
New York City and a member of the
digital marketing faculty it's simply
learned and today we're going to be
focusing specifically on what we can do
with email so hello and thanks for
joining us Matt how are you doing
alright Dan thanks for the invitation to
present here and I'm doing well I let
yourself really good thank you this was
an exciting topic because email is one
of the things that we get the most
questions on because it's always
changing and I think that's one of the
most beautiful things about digital
marketing is that it's measurable and
few things are as measurable as email we
really know what our rates are and so a
lot of these things are easy to test
what's more important is we want to make
sure we're doing it the right way and a
circle way so thanks for helping us out
today well I mean you've got that right
I mean email has been around even though
almost it's the beginning of the
internet emails been a part of it and
I'm amazed at how many people have
voiced said throughout the years the
emails going to die and emails going to
go away and or the email killer and and
what what do we have you know right now
we have email that that tops the list
when it comes to return on investment
when it comes to engagement when it
comes to you know reaching people one on
one email shows itself constantly to be
the number one channel to you know to
reach your existing customers as well as
to follow up and nurture prospects to
become customers
yeah it's hard to believe that email is
almost 50 years old those of us that are
were around that's what we're gonna
learn today
all right then well I'm going to start
with a couple of things and like you
mentioned things are changing and it's
not so much the technology of email it's
more the regulations that you really
need to keep aware of and the nice thing
is if you're using an email service
provider for the most part they are
going to keep you in line with the
regulations as a lot of the the impact
is going to hit the service provider but
as an account holder you are just as
responsible as your email service
provider to stay on the right side of
the regulations so the first part of
this is really going to be covering some
of the regulations out of gdpr but also
the California privacy law that is you
know it's it's moving forward it's going
backwards it's moving you know and
there's a lot of people trying to
toughen that law and there are a lot of
companies trying to weaken the law but
the trend is that regulations are going
to become much more restrictive on how
companies acquire data process data and
use it and so one of the things that you
absolutely have to do is provide crystal
clear terms of what you are going to do
with someone's information what that
means is you have to be clear what
you're going to do with their data if
you're simply going to store it or if
you're going to use it for segmentation
personalization marketing if you're
going to process it in any way and yes
segmenting it based on demographics
based on age gender you know what
products they like that is considered
processing data so even though it seems
as though that is the simplest thing you
can do with the data it's still
considered processing now especially if
you are going to share that data with
third parties now it may be
anonymized but in order to work with a
third party in order to find out more
about your customers that is another
level of processing the data and that
needs to be disclosed up front so the
more disclosure you make up front that
you will be processing the data you will
be segmenting you will be presenting
offers based on the data the more that's
going to keep you in the clear and keep
you on the right side of these
regulations
now the second thing is offering clear
consent options this is where a lot of
companies are having trouble or issues
because there's a lot of things that you
have to change if you have a change the
way that you are getting subscribers in
the past few years this is where the
trouble is this means that there must be
clear consent terms what that means is
you can't pre-check a box for people to
subscribe or to agree to the terms of
service it needs to be clear this is
called express consent this means that
people have to opt in so you can't
pre-check anything the user has to check
the Box themselves this means that
everything has to be opt in years ago
people would usually default to doing an
opt-out that if you bought something
downloaded something you are
automatically opted in and people had to
opt out now the laws and regulations
favor consumers so that they have to
make an expressed clear opt-in action
such as that checkbox so if you are
using anything that is pre checked
change that right now change it and go
to an uncheck and let the user check the
box and that will clear you
and let me move forward here there we go
okay uh anything that could be shown as
unambiguous consent that means it's got
to be very very clear what the user is
going to receive what you are going to
do with their data and they opt in now
one of the ways you can protect yourself
beyond the regulation is to do the
double opt-in the double opt-in is where
the user who subscribes or gives you
their information receives an email
verifying that they have opted in and
they need to click the link to verify
their subscription now this is not a
required step but it is recommended by
every email service provider it will
give you that extra layer of protection
that not only do you have a record of
the subscriber opting in but you also
have a record of them opting in that
second time with that verification email
that proof of consent is going to be big
because that is requirement under gdpr
is that you know what form was used to
gain that consent you know which landing
page they were on to originally sign up
or subscribe and so having that proof of
consent really keeps you safe and if
you're using an email service provider
all those records will be automatically
kept
now as an example of clear consent this
is one it's I love it because it's so
simple all it says is subscribe to our
newsletters and your name and email this
is clear because it tells you this is
how the data will be used and if all you
do is send newsletters with this list
that's generated by this forum you're
great
there's no checkbox required so gdpr
does not require checkboxes ok what GDP
requires is clear consent terms this is
an example of a clear consent term
because there's only one option and if
you want it you submit your information
so I hope that clarifies because many
people get the checkbox issue blown out
of proportion all you have to be is
clear as to what you're going to do with
the information and what people are
receiving in return so this is a great
example of how to show clear consent
terms and gather information
now also the other part of this is you
also have to make it easy for people to
unsubscribe what that means is in every
email there needs to be an unsubscribe
link and when someone clicks that link
you have to make it easy for them to
unsubscribe so this does not require me
to put in my first name and last name
I can hit unsubscribe from there what
this means is you cannot charge a fee
for someone to unsubscribe you should
not require them to log in and provide
any additional information this must be
a one page no process required anyone
that is requiring you to log in add more
information or anything like that that
is not covered in fact that what that
does is if you put any obstacle besides
a single click to unsubscribe on that
page then you could find yourself in
trouble with gdpr
pass and also with the California
regulations as well those are really
consumer friendly as far as allowing
opt-out and so be sure that you're not
requiring people to jump through a lot
of actions that will inhibit them from
unsubscribing you also have to have a
record so not only do you have to keep a
record of when they opted in and how you
receive that information such as the
landing page and the opt-in information
you also need to maintain that record of
when they opted out and how they opted
out to unsubscribe from communications
again if you're using any SP that will
help you now
when I see a problem here is when people
combine consent and really what you're
doing is trapping people you are
trapping people to really purchase a
product and consent to something at the
same time and that's called bundling you
can't do that let me give you an example
here this is the good part ok this is it
this is an opt-in consent that provides
separate opt-in for each offer so if I
am purchasing something at an e-commerce
site I have to accept the Terms of
Service I can do that however I also
have to make a separate opt-in consent
to receive email you cannot bundle these
together that I have to opt-in to Terms
of Service and automatically be
subscribed to the email those are two
separate offers two separate things that
require a separate opt-in so this is
good this is exactly how it should be
presented how it should not be done is
this way this is actually a I was on a
web site trying to buy something and I
had to check I have read the Terms and
Conditions and the privacy policy and
agree now what does that require if you
look underneath underneath there it says
in order to keep you up to date we will
send you the newsletter that was a
requirement of the terms and conditions
and in order to check out I had to agree
to the Terms of Service which implied
that I would receive the email so that
was bundling and opt in to the email in
order to check out that is holding your
user hostage and that is leveraging them
to opt into a bundled option so no do
not do this and I hope these things are
crystal clear because these are the
things that will trip up companies as
more gdpr
and more consumer friendly regulations
are implemented
um now actually I want to go back to
this is are there any questions at all I
think I've been very clear about the
bundled opt-ins are there any questions
that anyone has to this point about
bundling and clear consent terms
you
all right great okay pop-ups if you're
like me I'm on a page to read an article
and as soon as I get to that page I get
this pop-up now there are pop-ups that
offer me 10% off their pop-ups that
offer me you know all kinds of things uh
and then in reality I just want to read
this article or I just got to the
website and immediately I'm faced with a
pop-up uh I got one the other day that
allowed me to save 15% of my first order
the thing is I'm just there in a shop
and look and see what's there so if I
dismiss this do I not get the 15% you
know there's a lot of questions about
pop-ups do they really work are they
annoying what's going on with them now
there's good and bad looking at a lot of
the studies and a lot of the research
number one these pop-ups they do
increase conversions and they do
increase subscribers all right that's
the good side and here's what's
interesting about that the good side are
all about those upfront metrics okay
what I mean by the upfront metrics these
are the people that they subscribe so we
see our subscriptions go up and we see
conversion rates go up the backend
metrics this gets into so beyond your
your conversion rate
gets into brand and it also gets into
customer lifetime value which measures
the value of a customer over their
lifetime with a brand all right so
here's the downside the downside is
people don't like them even though it
increases subscribe versions rates there
is also a little bit of irritation with
users it may damage your brand but
here's what blows my mind but most is
that subscribers generated from the
popups have lower engagement and lower
lifetime value which means you may get
the sale upfront because you offered
them a discount but over the full life
of that customer they may end up being a
lower value customer who may cost you
more in the long run and customers
generated by other means so it really
takes more than just that entry level
measurement of hey we're getting
subscribers and they're buying something
we are offering them a 15% discount to
buy something what happens when that
discount is no longer there are you
comparing your customers that you've
acquired from other means or that were
acquired without the pop-up to the
customers acquired through a pop-up in
comparing their lifetime value or their
value over a year or quarter so don't
just look at the entry level metrics or
the superficial level metrics look
beyond to see are we getting quality
customers who are with us over the long
haul and not here just for that
temporary discount
so here are some best practices number
one don't immediately show the pop up as
soon as someone gets to the website now
this this is I think so important and
because usually when I run into these
pop ups I'm trying to read an article
that's my first goal that is my first
thing that I want to accomplish is
something about that article has
convinced me to be there and if you
interrupt the reading of that article
with an immediate pop-up you've
automatically damaged and inhibited me
from accomplishing my objective
so usually your your best practices put
the pop-up anywhere between 30 and 60
seconds into the visit and the best
place to do it is blog posts and
articles okay so you you have to ask
where the value is to the reader alright
let them meet their objective first
which is getting the information they
want and then tightening that pop-up
sufficiently to let them see the
information find the value from the
information that you've published and
then present the Papa one thing that
overwhelmingly will cause people to get
frustrated is if you use those exit
pop-ups which present or prevent people
from leaving your site like going to the
back button that can cause a lot of
problems and people love to complain
about those but you have to look at
allowing people to accomplish what they
want rather than per interrupting the
objective in order to get that
subscription
the next thing is personalization
personalization and we see this
constantly that if you start
personalizing the subject line it
immediately increases your open and
click rates and personalization is not
just using someone's name that's the
number one the easiest thing to do is
personalizing however even in this day
and age of personalization
I am shocked and amazed at how many
emails I get with the the parentheses
and the variable for first name I'm
amazed at how many companies are getting
this wrong and sending emails with the
database call out rather than testing it
to see if it works so even though
personalization is so big I'm amazed at
how many emails are being sent from
companies that aren't testing to make
sure the personalization database
call-out is working the other question
that I have about this is if you have a
forum where you're collecting email
you've got your database a lot of people
either put no information in there or
your field is missing or it's not
connecting people put in like Mickey
Mouse as the as the name or just a bogus
email address or something as the first
name and you really have to pay
attention to your form going out so that
you have something to compensate for
people that do that or missing field one
of the do you have any suggestions for
that I've seen one where you simply put
there instead of like Hello because it
because if I feel is missing then then
what happens what are some best
practices to protect yourself if you
have some missing data in your database
uh well some ISPs will run against the
database and provide you a report of
blank fields or things like that so that
you can either fix them or be aware one
of the biggest things I've seen is when
people have a single name field rather
than a
first name and last name surname type of
thing if you've got one field for name
then you you are just waiting for
problems that's your trick no one knows
how to now is it that with that if
you're there a is there a way that you
can concatenate stuff like that I know
you can use it in a maybe we're getting
the deep maybe we're getting kind of the
weeds here as far as using Excel or or
something that but there are ways that
you can split names up in your database
file so I think have I think what you
pointed out at the beginning of
answering this question is is prime that
you really have to look at your list and
clean it and take a glance at it and
test just to make sure there aren't any
holes in it well that's the biggest
thing is test uh you know there's got to
be a test group within your own
organization or or even if it's just you
there has to be a test group and every
email service provider enables you to
send tests to yourself before you hit
Send um and in that test group you
should have people looking at it
on their mobile device people looking at
it other desktop you know across
platforms in that way you will know for
sure that your subject line is carrying
the variables as well as rendering on
each of those devices I'm frankly
shocked that people don't do that um and
there's no limit you know I even just
myself my own list I think we probably
test it four or five times before we
even set it out just to make sure that
everything's working as it should
everyone has to sign off on it and then
it goes but that's probably the that's
probably the number one best practice
it's just the test and have a group of
people look at it rekt critics
well personalization is more than just
getting that name in there even though
getting a name into the subject line
increases your metrics of opens clicks
and engagement personalization
is it's what I just did it's what I'm
interested in it's where I was it's you
know personalization goes beyond the
name it goes into the intent of that
person and what they've done to express
intent
that's why birthday emails where you
wish someone happy birthday if that's in
your database they get open and clicked
on more it personalization is more about
relevance than just name and so if you
give them a personalized email and let
them know that you know you just looked
at this and don't forget about it or
something like that that is
personalization so it's not just the
name its intent its relevance that is
what personalization is all about
sometimes I think it's all wrapped up
into the name where it's more about
understanding that people are interested
in different things and recognizing that
yeah like dear Bob as you know Bob our
sale is continuing Bob so please call us
mom yeah yeah that's not that's not
personalization I got one the other day
about I'm trying to think what it was uh
but I think I had bought something uh at
a company and then about a month later I
got an email that something similar uh
that I had looked at on the site but did
not buy uh was no you know on sale or
special something like that I'm like nah
that's fitting that is such a great
example of personal as it can is they
used my past browsing data and a month
later somehow it's on sale if you know
and then letting me know the DAX
personalization yeah
great
the next thing and and this was dan and
i have been talking about this i think
for the past couple months is the box
are coming they're coming to take your
job all right that's what's happening
what we're seeing is AI is being used
you know machine learning is all about
learning what people like AI is when it
takes machine learning and makes
decisions based on that all right I hope
that clarifies the the terminology there
but what's happening here is companies
using AI are seeing the what I call the
the front end metrics increased
dramatically and by that AI is writing
the headlines of emails and what they
saw here is there was a four hundred and
fifty percent increase for JPMorgan
Chase Bank of eight eye box writing
titles and in every test it outperformed
humans who are copywriting or writing
the titles now I have no problem with
this because really what it's doing is
utilizing old direct mail techniques
what direct mail techniques work was
testing different copy different
headlines and seeing what it produced
and so that was what is happening with
AI is it's testing different options but
it's testing them faster and it's
testing to see what exactly are the
words that trigger people to click and
it's doing it faster than humans it's
sifting through the information and
finding patterns that humans may not
find and so as humans were writing
titles that we think are going to work
based on our experience based on our
knowledge and input whereas a bot is not
coming from that same experience it's
coming at it from a very different angle
all about performance and what is the
audience what what are they looking for
and so they're able to figure out those
triggers fast
and better than humans and so that's why
we're seeing in these types of scenarios
we're seeing AI vastly outperform humans
and I think we're going to see a lot
more of this happening now eventually
will they take over the whole aspect of
copywriting and developing content
beyond the headline probably I don't
think it's out of the realm of
possibility but at the same time it's
going to take humans to provide that
oversight that AI may not understand so
a great example this I forget again and
I were talking about this is what if and
we've seen this before where email
sometimes go out with a misspelling more
a you know something's not right and it
causes people to click and it causes
people to open and all the success
metrics are hit so what happens if AI
learns that a misspelling increases
clicks conversions and those types of
things if there's no guardrails then you
may start seeing more and more
misspellings happening because it
produces the right results and you've
got to ask yourself at what point does
it harm the brand so that's where you're
going to need to see some humans mm-hmm
hitting those guardrails - ai
yeah dan I know we had talking about a
little bit yeah that's that's a good
point it's hard to tell because one of
the things that it can't analyze is how
many people are sending you angry
letters saying oh you don't know the
difference between you your and your and
and so it just just because somebody
clicks through doesn't necessarily mean
that it's a response that you want even
though you know they can they can say
that you know every response is a good
response because then you have some sort
of engagement you can take care of but
but yeah I think that the brand harm is
a big issue because as many people as
click through to remind you of a problem
there is there probably a lot more
people that are simply going to turn
their back on your brand so yeah that's
an interesting point to be able to put
up guard wheels that's a that's a great
thing we should tell all the people in
AI but I'm just waiting for a bot to be
invented to read my email and tell me
what is the site of relevant it probably
already exists but pretty soon it's just
going to be the boss emailing the Box
you know I I think that's a great
possibility because if someone comes out
with a bot that will go through all my
email and only show me the five
important ones ah you go back I can't
think of a better way to same time in my
day there's there's our million dollar
idea all your day to scientists out
there you're listening Russian if you're
listening create a bot that reads my
email yeah so yeah and then I think your
point Bella BOTS writing for BOTS that's
exactly what's happening is you know so
we're seeing more box right social media
posts well those social media posts have
to perform in the algorithm so the
algorithm is machine learning trying to
find out what people want the posts are
being written by machine learning and so
it's going to be very interesting to see
how these next few years layout yeah
maybe there's hope for direct mail could
be could be but yeah I that's what's
really interesting and so part of this
with AI machine learning and my biggest
question is how far down the funnel are
the success metrics
being applied to provide the feedback
for AI so you know for example all
you're using is a click-through rate and
that's all AI is looking at is to
perform to a click-through rate then you
could see amazing thing that's happening
to get that click the rate but if AI is
looking all the way through those funnel
metrics of conversions of customer
lifetime value you know more of at the
bottom of the funnel full length full
customer journey metrics then I think
you're going to see it a bit more
reserved and focused in how it will grow
rather than you know increase in clicks
is that our bottom line metric or is it
increase in customer lifetime value
that's going to greatly affect how AI
performs
okay the next thing and this is a trend
that I am seeing and technology is
really kind of helping with this and I'm
just calling it insanely great landing
pages I mean there are some incredible
landing pages being designed right now
and the thing is you've got to stand out
from everybody it's the main difference
right now if you've got competitors in
the space you've got to stand out and
show how different you are and making a
splash and the landing page is one of
the primary ways of doing that I love
this one with Dropbox where if you're
going to sign up for Dropbox instead of
putting a bunch of content in front of
people just haven't watch a video I
loved it and they've got the button to
download Dropbox right there in the
video so just simple clean watch the
video and there you have it I love that
and I'm seeing so many more of these
Hawaiian Airlines has got a landing page
where they're actually talking about
their employees they're showing how they
paint the airplanes it just all kinds of
stuff about the airlines but it's
immersive about the brand their culture
their people it's a fantastic way of
presenting a story about your brand and
about your company rather than just
simply grabbing information from the
subscriber sprout for a webinar here um
you can view upcoming webinars you can
you can jump in but I just thought it's
insanely simple a great way of getting
people's information and this is sort of
that gateway landing page where people
hit it and then they hit the view
upcoming webinars and then they land on
another page for their and what I
thought was great so this was a
marketing automation and from this I
filled out I believe it was a white
paper from shark spring on their landing
page and this is the I guess you could
call it it's the landing landing page
because I hit the landing page I
subscribed and after I
that's it I was looking for that
infographic and I had to register to get
the infographic so after the landing
page I got sent to this page so rather
than just a simple thank you for
subscribing thank you for doing this
your infographics on his way they put a
video demo in the landing page of the
landing page and just asking me for a
mote of my time here's a less than
two-minute video and then pushing me
into registering for a demo fantastic
great way there's so many landing pages
that I have seen where once you complete
the landing page you're at a blue page
it says thank you and it doesn't move
you to that next stage of the funnel
this is what's happening here sharp
spring is they're using an infographic
as the bait and then they're giving you
further in with the video and they
ultimately to get you to sign up for a
demo so utilize the Thank You pages of
your landing pages to move people along
and get them into that next stage
you know that we worked with the company
once we're ready landing page was to get
people to sign up for a phone call from
a representative in order to go through
and work with them because it was kind
of a customized product and what we
realized is if they did not close the
the registration or close the deal on
that phone call then the second phone
call only had about a five to eight
percent success rate uh it you know the
success rate was closer to 60 to 70 on
the first phone call a second phone call
was 5 to 8 percent phenomenal drop by
and so what we found out is what what
contributed to that second phone call
was when people didn't have the
documentation and the information they
needed on the first phone call and so
all we did was change the landing page
so when people would fill out the
landing page and say call me at this
time the Thank You page would then give
them a printable checklist of the
information they needed for the phone
call
and in doing that it raised the first
phone call conversion rate by like 25
percent it was just phenomenal and they
had never thought of that before of
saying here's the information you need
and it was all in the pre conversion
information but it was never presented
as a here's a list print it get it
together for your phone call at this
time just doing that increase their
business it increased their
profitability it increased it and it was
such a simple move by utilizing that
Thank You page
you
all right retargeting emails now this
happens with people who are already a
customer people who are already part of
your brand they and they're registered
your email service provider your
e-commerce management program your your
CRM all of them can utilize this so this
is an example with MailChimp from their
blog where they talked about this
ecommerce provider here by just
retargeting what people looked at so
these are existing customers who went to
this website browsed a couple of
products they retargeted them the next
day the open rate was 41% that generated
a almost $1200 in revenue the first
month in implementing it
second thing as far as newer technology
is what's called real-time emails this
is allowing more interaction and
engagement at the email level within
your email window rather than clicking
through and going to the landing page so
here's a great example of a email from
bien tu and you can interact with the
email like it is a webpage and as you
would tap so this is designed for mobile
and so as you would tap each of the
navigation items the background changed
the call-to-action change and you could
get more information all within the
email and when you put see more that's
when you went to the website but other
than that all of this would work with an
email and so dynamically your email
within your own email window is is now a
way to engage with people and rather
than just giving a more static approach
a great example of this is kind of a
scratch and win where they can engage
with the email and scratch the options
to find uh you know here's the promotion
get the one you want and so again people
can interact with it it's dynamic it
allows movement activity going on
without having to click through another
one here uh and I've seen this and it
utilized in so many different ways is
Tim Berlin here is giving a weather
forecast the weather forecast is pulling
live data based on the IP address of the
user I think there might be another
factor going in there so regardless of
where you open this email it's your
weather and so a great example of how to
integrate data from other sources to
provide a more relevant and personalized
email
finally it's all about the money all of
these things are great and I've talked
about this it's been the the background
theme of the entire webinar is are you
tracking that full-length funnel are you
tracking the customer value all the way
through what that means is if what you
should be tracking is your revenue per
email so if you're doing a retargeting
campaign what's your revenue per email
for that campaign you're doing an
onboarding campaign what's your revenue
per email for that what's the average
revenue per email and dividing up your
campaigns which ones are designed to
produce revenue which ones are designed
to produce loyalty which ones are
designed to produce actions such as
ratings or something like that and track
your every mail per campaign and then
let that influence then it then work all
the way through to your average customer
lifetime value and how that's affected
by email based on where they came from
based on the campaign that brought them
there based on the amount of
interactions or sales or upsells look at
your conversions per campaign sales per
campaign don't just look at those those
top level metrics of opens and clicks
and conversions go deeper into the
funnel one of the best things I always
recommend is what's called the RFS
recency frequency and spend how much are
people spending how often are they
spending it when's the last time they
spent it if you're looking deeper into
those types of metrics and applying them
into your revenue calculations or your
engagement calculations you're going to
receive a lot more information about
what makes a successful campaign what
people like and what drives a more
profitable customer than simply looking
at those top level metrics
so damn that's it for me open for some
questions if we're ready sure you know
one of the things talked about laws
let's give a little refresher on
can-spam this this our favorite our
favorite email law goes back to 2003 and
it might be nice to talk about and what
exactly it's about and what people a lot
of people are ignoring I can't tell you
how many emails I'm getting from very
large companies as a matter of fact that
are seem to be lacking a lot of the
important things such as even something
obvious like an unsubscribe link or a
lot of people don't realize that the
fine for not having a compliant can spam
email is if you're reported is is
sixteen thousand dollars per occurrence
so who you know kind of runs through
what can spam means and what and and how
we can what we can do to protect
ourselves to make sure we have all that
data in there I mean it's pretty easy to
just look it up and make sure that
you're complying if you're working with
an ESP I'm sure that helps but what are
your thoughts on can spam and is it's
even still relevant it's completely
relevant and what I find interesting is
the so the companies that are not
complying with camp spam are doing their
own email they're not using an email
service provider because if you're using
the email service provider cost to
contact MailChimp yeah you know any of
those that unsubscribe link is part of
the email you can't remove it
because they are keeping you compliant
the the most amount of companies that I
see breaking this are probably using
their own email server in order to get
around it mm-hmm and yeah the biggest
thing that I see is a lack of an
unsubscribe if you get an email that
says to unsubscribe reply and type
unsubscribe that's completely illegal
yeah you can spam uh and believe me I
I've been keeping a record of who's
doing this you know and I'm kind of
wondering who gets that sixteen thousand
do I get it or this is someone else
present
would that the other thing is you can't
have an email subject line that pretends
that there is existing an existing
relationship or an existing thread what
that means is if you receive an email
with ar e which means that it's a reply
but it's not a reply to a conversation
that actually happened it's deceptive so
deceptive e else line subjects are
completely illegal according to can spam
so which is amazing because I still get
some of those I still see them pop up
now a lot of it is it's happening with
email servers and spam happening outside
of the country and so trying to track
down who's doing that is very difficult
but once in a while I do see people
doing that and what's amazing Dan is I'm
seeing this happening on LinkedIn um now
with lyft of some of the the we are
being approached by businesses on
LinkedIn they're doing things in the
subject line with LinkedIn in mail that
that would violate can spam so yeah but
it's tricky it's just the two biggest
thing is allow people to unsubscribe and
don't try and trick them with a subject
line yeah unclean spam great good device
how do you report people for violating
can spam it's supposed to be through the
FTC um but the the for what I understand
the backlog and be in very egregious
cases uh they'll take it on I haven't
seen like low-level stuff happen right
much yeah so here's a question what is a
good email provider to use that can do a
good job of segmenting and it's cost
effective for a small business that has
an email list of approximately a hundred
thousand subscribers I know this is a
this is uh this is like in the product
recommendation category but any ideas of
where they could look oh there's so many
you can use
many times depending upon the amount of
subscribers you you know I think if it's
under a certain amount you may get a
free account um it's usually based on
the amount of subscribers in your list
uh but even if it's not free I'll tell
you what it's going to be low-cost for
first a list that like that look at
MailChimp look at Emma or Constant
Contact um it those are probably your
top three as far as small business and
then you can grow into other things um
but those are the ones that I would
start with just look and see you know
what features are most important to you
and what will integrate with you know
with with your database as far as if it
would agree with your website and things
like that right I just want to say
thanks again Matt for joining us and
it's been a pleasure knocking these
ideas around with you yeah
always look forward to the next one
thanks again everyone for joining us and
keep your email legal bye bye
[Music]